Bonjour à tous ! Aujourd'hui on va parler de l'infini.
Et ouais, rien que ça.
L'infini, il y a plusieurs manières de l'envisager
suivant que l'on prend le point de vue
du mathématicien, du physicien ou bien du philosophe.
Dans cette vidéo, je ne vais pas avoir
le temps de parler de tout ça à la fois,
donc je vais me concentrer sur un aspect
particulier qui est l'infini en mathématiques
et plus précisément les ensembles infinis.
♪ [Générique] ♪
En mathématiques il y a plusieurs manières
d'approcher le concept d'infini
et une des manières les plus élémentaires
est celle de la théorie des ensembles.
En mathématiques on manipule souvent des ensembles,
c'est-à-dire des collections de trucs
et les trucs, on appelle ça des éléments.
On peut faire des ensembles un peu de ce qu'on veut,
des ensembles de nombres, de figures
géométriques, de fonctions, etc ...
Une des choses les plus simples dont
on puisse parler à propos d'un ensemble
c'est sa taille, c'est-à-dire le nombre d'éléments qu'il contient
et on appelle ça son cardinal.
Par exemple, le cardinal de cet ensemble est 6,
celui-là 4, celui-là 7, etc ...
Un des tout premiers ensembles
qu'on considère quand on fait des maths
c'est celui des nombres entiers positifs,
c'est-à-dire 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, etc...
On appelle ça les entiers naturels qu'on note N, comme ça.
A votre avis, c'est quoi le cardinal
de l'ensemble des entiers naturels ?
Il y en a combien des entiers naturels, et bien...
il y en a une infinité, non ?
Et oui, et on peut même prendre ça comme définition de l'infini,
on va dire que l'infini c'est le cardinal
de l'ensemble des entiers naturels
et on note ça avec ce symbole
que vous connaissez certainement
qui ressemble à un 8 couché et qu'on appelle le lemniscate.
Ok, donc on a une définition de l'infini, c'est le cardinal
de N, on va voir un peu où ça nous mène.
Quand on considère un ensemble,
il y a cette idée un petit peu intuitive
que, si on ne prend qu'une partie de cet ensemble
son cardinal doit être forcement
plus petit, ça parait assez logique.
Voyons ce que ça donne avec des entiers naturels.
On va considérer N donc, l'ensemble des entiers naturels
et on va considérer à côté un autre ensemble,
l'ensemble des entiers plus grands que -1,
c'est-à-dire -1, 0, 1, 2, 3, etc...
et cet ensemble on va l'appeler E.
Vous voyez que E est la même chose que N,
on a juste ajouté un élément qui est le nombre -1.
Le cardinal de cet ensemble E, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Et bien, intuitivement on sent bien que c'est l'infini aussi mais ...
en même temps on sent bien que E
est quand même plus grand que N
donc est-ce que c'est vraiment le même infini
ou est-ce que c'est un infini plus gros auquel il faudrait,
par exemple, donner un autre symbole.
En fait, ce qui nous manque ici
c'est un moyen de comparer les infinis.
Pour essayer d'y voir un petit peu plus clair, on peut avoir
recours à un petit jeu qui s'appelle l’hôtel de Hilbert.
L’hôtel de Hilbert est une petite énigme
qui a été proposée pour la première fois
par le mathématicien David Hilbert.
Imaginez qu'on ait un hôtel qui ait une infinité de chambres
qui soient numérotées par les nombres entiers naturels,
donc il y a la chambre 0, la chambre 1, la chambre 2, etc...
Maintenant supposons que toutes les chambres sans
exception soient occupées chacune par une personne.
Tout va bien jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un
se pointe à la réception de l'hôtel
et demande s'il n'y aurait pas une chambre de libre.
Là, le gérant répond que non, il n'y a pas
de chambre libre puisque l'hôtel est plein.
Et là, le type qui vient d'arriver, qui en fait est
mathématicien dit, non, en fait il y a une solution,
il suffit de dire à chaque personne présente dans l'hôtel
d'aller dans la chambre suivante.
Celui qui est actuellement dans
la chambre 0 va dans la chambre 1,
celui qui est dans la chambre 1 va dans la 2, etc ...
Avec ça tout le monde est relogé,
sauf que la chambre 0 devient libre
et le type peut s'y installer.
Problème résolu.
Là, on vient de faire quelque chose qui est très intéressant,
on a pris l'ensemble des personnes présentes
dans l'hôtel, c'est-à-dire tous ceux qui étaient déjà là,
plus le nouveau venu
et on leur a attribué un nouveau numéro de chambre
de sorte que chaque chambre contienne exactement
une personne et chaque personne ait sa chambre à lui.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a établi une correspondance parfaite
entre les personnes présentes et les chambres,
on les a appariées.
En terme technique quand on fait ça, on appelle ça une bijection
et la définition qu'on va prendre
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on peut faire
une bijection entre deux ensembles,
qu'on peut vraiment apparier leurs éléments deux à deux,
les deux ensembles ont le même cardinal.
Donc là, on a moyen de comparer les tailles d'ensembles infinis,
il suffit de voir si on peut faire une bijection entre eux
et donc en particulier si on a un ensemble
et qu'on peut montrer qu'on peut faire une bijection
entre cet ensemble et l'ensemble N des entiers naturels,
ça veut dire qu'ils ont le même cardinal,
l'infini, celui qu'on a déjà vu
et qu'on a noté avec le lemniscate.
Faire une bijection avec N, l'ensemble des entiers naturels,
c'est un bien grand mot pour dire numéroter.
Si vous avez un ensemble et
que vous pouvez numéroter ses éléments,
alors vous pouvez créer une bijection
entre cet ensemble et N
et donc cet ensemble aura le même cardinal que N.
Ça, ça permet de répondre à notre question
de tout à l'heure, notre ensemble E,
on peut le numéroter
et donc le cardinal de E est le même que celui de N,
c'est bien l'infini, le même infini.
Du coup, vous voyez qu'avec ce concept d'infini,
il se passe un truc bizarre,
en général quand on prend un ensemble et qu'on
considère seulement une sous-partie de cet ensemble,
son cardinal est plus petit.
Là ce n'est pas le cas, l'ensemble N
est strictement inclus dans l'ensemble E
et pourtant ils ont le même cardinal.
Cette situation est une des caractéristiques
et même des définitions possibles des ensembles infinis.
Bien sûr, on peut étendre plus loin
le petit jeu de l'hôtel de Hilbert,
si jamais il n'y a pas une personne qui se pointe
à la réception mais 42 personnes,
c'est facile, il suffit de décaler
de 42 chambres et le tour est joué.
Maintenant ce qu'on peut se demander,
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il se passe si arrive à la réception
un bus contenant une infinité de personnes.
Et bien on peut quand même s'en sortir
pour reloger tout le monde,
vous voyez comment ?
Pour ça, il suffit de dire à ceux qui sont déjà dans l’hôtel
de prendre la chambre dont le numéro
est le double de leur chambre actuelle.
Celui qui est dans la chambre 0
reste dans la chambre 0,
celui qui est dans la 1 va dans la 2,
celui qui est dans la 2 va dans la 4, etc ...
Et du coup, toutes les chambres impaires
sont libres pour les nouveaux arrivants
et on vide le bus en remplissant l'hôtel.
Ce qu'on a fait là à nouveau c'est une bijection
puisqu'on a pris l'ensemble des personnes présentes,
toutes celles qui sont dans l'hôtel
et toutes celles qui sont dans le bus
et on leur a filé un nouveau numéro de chambre
donc on a établi une bijection
entre l'ensemble des personnes présentes
et l'ensemble N des entiers naturels
et donc ça montre bien que
l'ensemble des personnes présentes
a un cardinal qui est aussi l'infini, le cardinal de N.
Mathématiquement, ce qu'on a fait là
c'est équivalent à montrer
que si on considère l'ensemble
des entiers positifs ou négatifs,
ce qu'on appelle l'ensemble des entiers relatifs,
on le note Z parfois,
son cardinal est le même que N
puisqu'on peut numéroter les entiers relatifs
comme ça, par exemple.
Vous voyez que comme pour nos personnes,
les numéros pairs sont attribués aux nombres positifs
et les numéros impairs sont attribués aux nombres négatifs.
Avec ce petit jeu de numérotation, on a montré
qu'il y avait autant d'entiers relatifs
que d'entiers naturels, ce qui est assez bizarre,
mais dans le même genre on peut aussi montrer
qu'il y a autant de nombre pairs que d'entiers naturels
autant de nombres qui sont des carrés, etc ...
Tous ces ensembles qui ont le même cardinal que N
parce qu'on arrive à les numéroter,
on dit qu'ils sont dénombrables.
Evidemment ce qu'on a envie de se demander,
c'est s'il n'existerait pas des ensembles infinis
qui soient vraiment plus gros que celui des entiers naturels,
des ensembles qu'on n'arriverait pas à numéroter
et donc qui ne seraient pas dénombrables.
Pour essayer de répondre à cette question,
on peut retourner dans l'hôtel de Hilbert.
♪ [Générique] ♪
On a vu que l'hôtel de Hilbert, même s'il était déjà plein,
et que se pointait un bus infini rempli de personnes,
on arrivait quand même à recaser tout le monde,
donc pour fabriquer un ensemble infini qui soit
vraiment plus gros que l'ensemble des entiers naturels,
il va falloir y aller un petit peu plus fort.
Reprenons l'hôtel et imaginons cette fois
que ce n'est pas un bus infini qui arrive,
mais une infinité de bus qui contiennent
chacun une infinité de personnes.
Alors, comment on fait ?
Là, vous vous dites peut-être que le gérant est coincé
et que cette fois ça fait vraiment beaucoup trop
de monde pour reloger dans l'hôtel de Hilbert.
Et non, on va voir une manière de s'en sortir
et en fait il y en a plusieurs.
Prenez toutes les personnes qui sont initialement dans l'hôtel
et relogez-les uniquement dans les chambres
qui sont des nombres premiers
donc la première personne, vous la mettez dans la chambre n°2,
la 2ème dans la 3, puis ensuite dans la 5,
dans la 7, dans la 11, dans la 13, etc ...
Il y a une infinité de nombres premiers donc
il n'y a aucun problème pour reloger tout le monde.
Ensuite, vous prenez le bus n° i
et vous prenez la personne assise à la place n° j
et vous la mettez dans la chambre
2 puissance i fois 3 puissance j.
Par exemple, si vous prenez le 2ème bus et la 1ère place,
la personne qui est là vous la mettez dans la chambre n°12
et vous voyez que ce n'est pas un nombre premier,
donc cette chambre est forcement libre.
Vous pouvez vous convaincre qu'avec cette numérotation,
on ne peut pas avoir deux personnes
qui se retrouvent dans la même chambre
et on peut reloger tout le monde.
Comme ça, non seulement on a réussi à caser tout
le monde, mais en plus il reste plein de places libres,
vous pouvez vous convaincre, par exemple,
que la chambre n°10 ou la chambre n°14,
à la fin elles sont toujours libres.
Mathématiquement, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que
cette nouvelle version du problème de l'hôtel de Hilbert ?
Quand tout le monde débarque à l'hôtel,
les personnes sont définies par une paire d'entiers,
le premier c'est le numéro du bus et le deuxième
c'est le numéro de la place où elles sont assises.
Donc, il y a autant de personnes présentes
que de paires d'entiers possibles,
ou une autre manière de le dire, il y en a autant
que de cases sur un damier infini.
Cet ensemble là, on l'appelle N² ou parfois N2.
Ce qu'on vient de faire en résolvant ce problème de l'hôtel,
c'est montrer que l'ensemble N² est dénombrable,
il a le même cardinal que N,
ce qui est quand même un peu contre-intuitif
parce qu'on a vraiment l'impression
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de cases que d'entiers naturels.
Pourtant, si vous n’êtes pas convaincus, je vous montre
une deuxième manière de numéroter cet ensemble.
Regardez, on met ici 0,
puis 1, 2
et 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, etc ...
Comme ça on peut établir une bijection entre N et N².
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe si on va encore plus loin ?
Imaginons qu'on ait une infinité de bateaux qui débarquent,
qui contiennent chacun une infinité de bus dans lesquels
il y a une infinité de personnes qui sont assises.
Et bien, on peut quand même s'en sortir,
je vous laisse trouver comment.
D'ailleurs, ça marche aussi avec
une infinité de vaisseaux spatiaux
qui débarqueraient une infinité de bateaux
contenant une infinité de bus, etc ...
Tout ça c'est quand même un peu décourageant, visiblement,
chaque fois qu'on essaie de construire un ensemble
qui serait vraiment plus gros
que l'ensemble des entiers naturels,
il semble que ça rate, on ne fabrique que des ensembles
qui en fait sont dénombrables,
c'est-à-dire qui sont en bijection
avec l'ensemble des entiers naturels.
Pour essayer de fabriquer un ensemble
qui serait vraiment plus gros,
il nous faut un ensemble qui ne soit pas dénombrable,
c'est-à-dire un ensemble qu'on ne puisse pas numéroter.
Et bien, un ensemble comme ça, il y en a un
qu'on connait, c'est l'ensemble des nombres réels.
Intuitivement, on sent bien qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de nombre réels que de nombres entiers
parce que les réels forment un continuum,
alors que les entiers, c'est quelque chose de discontinu.
Sauf que ça c'est intuitivement et jusqu'ici on a vu que
notre intuition ne nous a pas franchement aidés.
Alors, est-ce que c'est vraiment possible de démontrer rigoureusement
qu'il y a plus de réels que d'entiers?
Et bien oui, on peut.
Je ne vais pas vous donner la démonstration
dans le détail, mais elle n'est pas très compliquée,
elle est due à un mathématicien qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur l'infini, qui s'appelle Georg Cantor.
Le principe de la démonstration
est une démonstration par l'absurde.
On suppose qu'on peut numéroter
l'ensemble des nombres réels
et on montre que, dans ce cas là,
on arrive toujours à construire un nombre réel
qui n'était pas dans notre numérotation
de départ, donc on a une contradiction
et ça montre qu'en fait, l'ensemble
des nombres réels n'est pas dénombrable.
Donc, la conclusion de Cantor
est que le cardinal des nombres réels
est aussi l'infini, mais c'est un infini
qui est vraiment strictement plus gros
que celui dont on a parlé jusqu'ici, c'est un infini indénombrable.
Du coup ce qu'on peut faire, c'est le noter différemment,
on va choisir oméga (Ω).
Maintenant évidemment, il se passe avec
les nombres réels le même genre de bizarrerie
qu'il se passait déjà avec les nombres entiers naturels.
Considérez tous les nombres réels
qui sont strictement compris entre 0 et 1.
Intuitivement toujours, on a envie de penser
qu'il y a moins de nombres réels entre 0 et 1
que de nombres réels au total.
Et bien non, il y en a en quelque sorte autant.
Pour le montrer, il suffit de trouver une bijection
entre cet ensemble et l'ensemble des nombres réels.
Là par exemple, je vous en donne une.
Cette fonction envoie tous les nombres réels
qui sont compris entre 0 et 1
sur l'ensemble - l'infini, + l'infini et réciproquement
et donc cet ensemble et l'ensemble
des nombres réels ont le même cardinal, Ω.
Autre paradoxe apparent, on a envie de penser
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de points
dans un carré que dans un segment.
Et bien non, encore raté, on peut montrer qu'il y a
une bijection entre les deux avec l'astuce suivante.
Considérez un point x, y, dans le carré,
donc x et y sont tous les deux compris entre 0 et 1.
Décomposez chacun des nombres en écriture décimale
et fabriquez le point z sur le segment 0, 1,
en alternant les décimales de x et de y.
Donc à chaque point du carré correspond un unique
point du segment et réciproquement.
Donc ces deux ensembles
ont le même cardinal qui est aussi Ω.
Si on se creusait un petit peu la tête,
on pourrait aller encore plus loin
et fabriquer un ensemble dont le cardinal
serait vraiment plus grand que Ω.
Mais il y a une autre question qui est assez intéressante,
c'est de se demander s'il existe des ensembles infinis
qui sont en quelque sorte plus gros que les entiers
naturels mais plus petits que les nombres réels.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faudrait trouver un ensemble
dont le cardinal soit plus grand que celui de N
mais plus petit que celui de R,
une sorte d'infini intermédiaire entre les deux.
Des ensembles de ce genre là,
Cantor pensait qu'en fait il n'y en avait pas,
mais il ne savait pas le démontrer, alors
il a appelé cette idée "L'hypothèse du continu".
L'hypothèse du continu, il y a un certain nombre
de mathématiciens au cours du 20ème siècle
qui ont essayé de la démontrer ou alors
de trouver un contre-exemple,
c'est-à-dire de fabriquer un ensemble
qui soit plus grand que les nombres entiers,
mais plus petits que les nombres réels
et en fait ce n'est pas simple.
Intuitivement, on pourrait penser à
l'ensemble des nombres rationnels, les fractions.
On sent bien qu'il y a quand même beaucoup plus
de fractions que de nombres entiers,
mais moins que de nombres réels,
que c'est un truc un peu intermédiaire.
Et bien non. En fait, une fraction c'est quoi ?
C'est un numérateur et un dénominateur,
donc l'ensemble des fractions c'est en gros
l'ensemble des paires d'entiers, donc c'est N²
et on a vu que N² est dénombrable,
donc l'ensemble des fractions n'est pas
plus gros que l'ensemble des entiers naturels.
A l'heure qu'il est, on pourrait toujours être en train
de s'escrimer à essayer de trancher
la question de l'hypothèse du continu,
sauf qu'au milieu du 20ème siècle, il a été démontré
que cette question est indécidable.
Vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de cette idée et du théorème de Gödel
qui dit que, en mathématiques, à partir
d'un certain niveau de complexité,
il existe forcement des propositions
qu'on ne peut ni démontrer, ni infirmer.
Et bien l'hypothèse du continu, c'en est une,
c'est une question qu'on ne peut pas trancher,
ou plutôt dont la réponse dépend
du système d'axiomes qu'on utilise.
Si pour vous, tout ça c'est du chinois,
rassurez-vous je vais m’arrêter là,
mais je vous promets, un jour
je vous reparlerai du théorème de Gödel.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo,
si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager
pour m'aider à faire connaitre la chaîne.
Si le problème de Hilbert vous a amusé, vous pouvez
aller voir la vidéo de El JJ qui traite de ce sujet.
Vous pouvez me retrouver sur
les réseaux sociaux, Facebook, Twitter,
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir
sur Tipeee, merci beaucoup à tous les tipeurs
et vous pouvez aussi aller lire mon blog
qui s'appelle Science Étonnante.
Merci et à bientôt !